[Music]
today's question comes from tim in texas
tim writes my 37 year old daughter
recently entered rehab for alcoholism
well it's a difficult situation i'm very
grateful that she realizes she has a
problem and she's seeking help before
she went into rehab i learned that she
had twenty thousand dollars in credit
card debt she's talking about declaring
bankruptcy the tougher love part of me
says she needs it she needs to be
accountable and follow the baby steps
and work through her debt snowball to
pay it off the other part of me said
she's been through a tremendous ordeal
and she needs a fresh start and that i
should pay off the debt for her i'm
fortunate to be in a position where i
can easily do this given my daughter's
addiction pending recovery and negative
financial position what is the best
course of action concerning my
daughter's debt
dave i'd love to hear your thoughts on
this this one gets messy and you've
dealt with this for years and years and
years and years
oh it's your world man i mean it's um
there's a uh
i mean i've got a daughter of that age i
can imagine his heart's broken oh man
and he wants to help yeah and i
immediately wonder
um
if his enabling in the past has
something to do with her addiction yeah
or his yeah
so because he's trying to he's trying to
do it again or or is he just being
compassionate and loving and kind and
yeah you know it's the enablers are
always the nicest people yeah so i think
first it's important to note you take
bankruptcy off the table for twenty
thousand dollars yeah right like that's
off the table good point um
i
my understanding of the alcoholism rehab
world is like any other rehab world is
you begin to take ownership of your life
one tiny step at a time
and there's something here about
having a goal and 20 000 can feel like a
million i get that when i think of the
debt i owed it looks small but that's
gonna be a mountain for peop for folks
that you are gonna walk alongside her
you're gonna
have a weekly breakfast with her that
you're gonna set up that you're gonna
pay for you're gonna check on her how
her budgets are going and what she's
gonna get out of that is a new
relationship with you you're going to
tell her about times you screwed up with
money she's going to get to know you a
little bit better
y'all are going to high-five and
celebrate together she's going to fall
off the wagon you're going to weep
together and you're going to walk
alongside her and then she's going to
get the outsized gif of walking through
and solving this problem with her own
two hands and i think there's a gift
there and maybe at the end you gifted
the last five thousand bucks or last
something like that but there's
something about this
what i would do is i would i would just
modify that very very slightly because i
i just feel his father's heart on this
and it just compassion is dripping off
this email
his his
tears are on there um
and i really don't read any enabler
language no i don't either i don't i i
was reading into that but um
uh i think we exactly i'd do exactly
what you said um and i would pay for her
to go through financial peace university
and maybe even go to class with her yeah
and i would agree to match her hmm i
like that if she pays a thousand i'll
put a thousand oh i like that and so
i'll give her some encouragement but i'm
gonna participate in her healing
i'm not gonna try to do it for her yeah
i like that dave i like if you
yeah that's a that's a that's a great
olive branch i like that yeah and you're
you're you're coaching her you're
cheering for now that's you know
contingent upon her being on a budget
cutting up the credit cards you're not
going back and but as you know a little
part of your overall healing let's heal
your financial situation simultaneously
because they are overlapped and uh let's
do it together that's fun and i don't
know what a great day i don't know any
addiction challenges that don't have
relational challenges
as the foundation so there's probably
some healing here between dad and
daughter that are going to take place
anyway which is beautiful hey any
anybody that's an addict that's close to
you has pissed you off i'll just tell
you that there's no exception and
probably vice versa because they piss
off everybody around them it's part of
what they do
manipulative and they lie and uh it's a
mess just a mess